[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHRYN HURLEY: Hey, everyone.
My name's Kathryn Hurley.
I'm a developer programs
engineer at Google.
And this is Marc Cohen,
also a developer
programs engineer at Google.
MARC COHEN: Hello.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And we both work
on Google Compute Engine.
So in this session, we're going
to show you how to get
started using Google
Compute Engine.
So first, what is Google
Compute Engine?
It's a compute engine
just launched at--
[LOST AUDIO]
--infrastructure, what
it's all about.
Basically, this is what Google's
infrastructure
already handles.
It indexes billions--
[LOST AUDIO]
--data that's written to and
from your VMs, all the data is
encrypted, so it's
very secure.
Again, it's one of the
engineers' number-one
priorities.
Another guiding principle
was that the
system is open and flexible.
And basically, you're
given a VM.
You have root access to this VM,
so you can install pretty
much whatever you want on this
VM, which allows a very
flexible environment for you
to develop applications on.
The engineers were also
concerned about consistency.
So they want to make sure that
any application that you are
writing on your engine would
be consistent and run
consistently.
So it works once, and
it always works.
The system, Compute Engine,
is also proven.
So a lot of Google's production
services are
already running on
Compute Engine.
And finally--
MARC COHEN: So I just wanted
to stop you for a second.
I'm getting some reports that
people aren't getting audio
when we cut to the slides.
We're OK?
OK, it's fixed.
Sorry about the interruption.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Should I go back
and go over any of the
slides, or are we good?
MARC COHEN: Not sure how
much audio we lost.
Maybe carry on from where
you left off, perhaps.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And finally, the
engineers, and the team in
general, is just very interested
in enabling an
ecosystem on Compute Engine.
So we have an API that you can
use and incorporate into your
own applications.
So we're very interested in
partnering with you to help
you include Compute Engine
in your projects and
applications.
So what I wanted to do was just
jump into a little demo
right here right now and
show off the Google
Compute Engine UI.
And the UI is available in
the Google API Console.
I'm going to switch to
that view right now.
So if you just go to
code.google.com/apis/console,
this is Google's API Console,
and you have control over
several or all of Google APIs
we have in this console.
And you have the opportunity
to create projects.
Here I have a project called
Google Compute Engine that I'm
going to be working in.
And you can see some
information
about my project here.
And you can see I have
Google Compute Engine
enabled on my project.
And it looks like I don't have
access to this project.
Shoot.
I guess I can't have more
than one account.
Let me see.
Sorry.
MARC COHEN: You can sign
out and sign back in.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Give me
one second to sign out
and sign back in.
Sorry about the delay.
[TYPING]
KATHRYN HURLEY: All right.
Here we go.
So again, this is Google's
API Console.
And I was going to click
on Compute Engine here.
And you see I have Compute
Engine projects called
compute-engine-demo.
And you can see some information
about my Compute
Engine project.
I have 100 instances available,
100 CPUs, and some
other information.
I can see a list of
all the instances
I have up and running.
So I already have an instance
called demo-1 up and running.
I can create new disks here
if I want to do that.
I can just skip that for now.
And I can see information about
networks that I have in
my project and zones
and operations.
So let's just go back
to Instances.
And I want to create a new
instance now and just show you
how easy it is to get an
instance up and running.
So I click on Create
Instance button.
You can see there's a lot of
options here in this UI.
So I can give the
instance a name.
I'll just call this demo-2.
I can apply a description.
I can select which zone I want
the instance to get up and
running in.
I'll keep it the default
for now.
I can select the machine types,
which allows me to
select a number of virtual
CPUs for my instance.
I'll keep it as the default.
If I had images, Custom Image,
I could apply it, or I can
select from one of the many
default images to apply.
And there are several
other options.
But this looks good
for now, so I will
Create a New Instance.
And you can see this instance is
provisioning right now, and
it's going to go through
provisioning and staging and
get up and running.
And it's staging right now,
so it's pretty quick.
Let's just go and look
at this one that's
already up and running.
And you can see some information
about this
instance I've already started.
So you can see information about
the zone, machine type,
the disks that I have
for this image.
And what's pretty interesting
down here is this SSH command.
And I could just copy this and
paste it directly in my
terminal window, and this will
allow me to SSH directly into
this machine.
So that's pretty handy.
All right, so let's go
back to the slides.
So now I just want to talk about
the overview of Compute
Engine and talk about
some various
components of Compute Engine.
So first, we have the concept
of a project.
And I briefly showed you that
in the API Console.
That's an API console project,
and the project owns all of
these resources.
And then we have the compute
component of Compute Engine.
And that's basically your
VMs that are doing all
the work for you.
Next, we have the network and
storage and API and tools.
And I'm going to talk about each
of those individually.
So the Project, again,
it's based on
the API Console projects.
You create project in
the API Console.
And this project is a container
for all your Compute
Engine resources.
So the project owns the VMs.
It owns storage, networks,
et cetera.
And you can invite specific
team members to join the
project and work on that
project with you.
And also, billing is enabled
for that project.
The Compute powers the VMs,
and so these VMs are Linux
virtual machines.
You have root access to these
VMs, which means you can
basically install whatever
you want on it,
which is really cool.
You can choose from some
of the stock images.
We have Ubuntu and
CentOS images.
Or you can create your
own custom images to
apply to the VMs.
There's a modern processor--
Intel Sandy Bridge--
and you can select the number of
CPUs and RAM for your VMs.
Next is the Network.
So all the VMs live within their
own private network as
isolated per project.
You're given a private
IPv4 space.
And one thing I find pretty
cool is there's
internal-facing DNS.
So the names that you have
assigned to these VMs are also
the DNS names for the VMs.
So it's easy to communicate
within your
private network of VMs.
So you might also be interested
in allowing
communication with the external
world, so allowing
computers to connect to your
VMs or vice versa.
So each of the VMs has an
external IP assigned using
1-to-1 NAT.
And you can use firewalls to
allow TCP connections to your
VMs or allow other protocols.
Now, Storage.
So if you decide to do so,
you can have persistent
disk for your VMs.
And persistent disks are
provisioned via the API.
And they are located in the same
zone as that instance.
And since the team is very
concerned about security, they
are encrypted.
You can use ephemeral disk
instead, if you want to, or in
addition to your persistent
disk.
Ephemeral disk, it lives and
dies with the instance.
So as soon as that instance
shuts down, it's
also gone as well.
And that's because it lives on
the same physical machine as
that instance.
And again, this is also
encrypted at rest.
And finally, you can also
use cloud storage for
your storage needs.
And this is an internet
object store.
It's similar to EC2.
There's an API where you can
access the objects in your
cloud storage buckets.
What's really cool is there's
frictionless access to cloud
storage if you use
service accounts.
So basically, when you start
up a VM, you can say, OK, I
want this VM to be able to
access cloud storage as well.
And you can immediately use
gsutil on this VM without
having to worry about
OAuth at all.
So finally, we have a few tools
that you can use to
access Compute Engine.
There's a command line library
called gcutil, which makes it
really easy to add instances,
list instances, create
networks, et cetera.
I showed you the Compute
Engine UI, and that's
available in the API Console.
And then finally, there's
code, and that's you.
So we're very interested in
forming partners and creating
an ecosystem around
Compute Engine.
And we have an API that allows
you to use Compute Engine in
your applications.
So gcutil, I'll just go through
gcutil real quickly.
That's a command-line
utility library.
And here are a few examples of
the commands that you can run.
So you can start up a new
instance using the gcutil
addinstance, and you provide
a name for that instance.
You can list all the running
instances using listinstances.
You can even apply filters to
listing out the instances.
So if you want to find all the
instances that are running,
you can filter for status
equals RUNNING.
If you want to add a new
network, you can use
addnetwork and provide a
name for that network.
Here, we're calling it prod.
And finally, you can set up
a firewall to allow your
instances to accept incoming
HTTP connections.
All right.
So I was going to have an API
demo, but due to the account
issue, I'm wondering if
I should cancel that.
Can we switch away for a second
while I set it up?
Give me just one second
to set this up.
MARC COHEN: Just to amplify
the last point about the
network configuration--
just give me a yell
when you're ready.
Are you ready now?
KATHRYN HURLEY: Sure.
MARC COHEN: OK.
KATHRYN HURLEY: I can't
that works.
MARC COHEN: I'll finish
the thought.
Basically, Kathryn showed
a command line that was
configuring access to port
80 for the network.
And in case anyone was
wondering, you
don't have to do that.
By default, your network will
come up with the ability to
accept SSH connections.
So I think that's port 22 SSH?
I'm not exactly sure of the port
number, but it'll accept
SSH connections from
virtually anywhere.
And it will accept any allow all
traffic between instances
within a given virtual
network or cluster.
Other than that, you would
want to use that command
Kathryn showed you to augment
the firewalls to allow
additional access.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And
yes, it is 22.
MARC COHEN: Cool.
KATHRYN HURLEY: All right,
should we go
through the demo now?
MARC COHEN: Sure.
KATHRYN HURLEY: OK, just
real quick, I'll go
through this demo.
So I set up this little
App Engine app
that starts up instances.
And I'll get those up and
running right now.
And basically, this App
Engine app uses an
App Engine task queue.
And so the App Engine
app sends these
tasks to the task queue.
And each task is going to
start up a VM using the
Compute Engine API.
And you can see, these are all
the VMs I've asked Compute
Engine to get started running.
And as they turn from red
to yellow to green, that
indicates the various status
of the instances.
So red is when they're
provisioning.
Orange is when they
are staging.
And green is when they're
actually running.
So when they're up and running,
they get placed in
this little waiting period.
So they're basically waiting for
a file to get uploaded to
cloud storage.
So when I click at this Fractal
Time button, there's
going to a file that's uploaded
to cloud storage, and
all of VMs are going to be,
OK, the file's there.
And so they'll continue at their
work, and they're all
going to generate one tile
for this fractal image.
And as you can see, they're
filling in all
the tiles right now.
So that's basic API demo.
You can do so much more
with the API.
But this gives you an idea of
the kind of thing that you can
get up and running
really quickly.
This took me less than a week
to get up and running.
MARC COHEN: And we're going to
make this available soon.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes, so we're
going to share the code with
you to help you learn
how to use the API.
And let me just go
back real quick.
So a little bit about the API.
It's a REST API.
And here's just a basic example
of an HTTP request
that you make to
start up a VM.
So you send a POST request
to this URL.
And then you send--
ooh, that's very yellow.
You send a JSON object
representing the instance that
you want up and running.
So I just want to provide
a couple of
helpful links to you.
So you can sign up for
Compute Engine here.
It has a few instructions
of what to do.
And I also want to provide a
link to the docs so you can
read the docs this URL.
All right.
Thank you.
That's all I have.
Here's some information about
me if you want to get
in touch with me.
I'll leave that up for just
maybe a couple of seconds.
And I think at this point,
we're going to go to the
moderator that we had and answer
the questions that
people had posted.
The moderator was available
in the Google
Developer Live session.
And I think we can just read off
those questions and answer
them, so if you don't
mind helping out.
MARC COHEN: Sure.
Yes.
We have the top question right
now is "Do you have API client
libraries and for
what language?"
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes.
MARC COHEN: We do
have languages.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes.
Let's see.
I can even try to find--
MARC COHEN: So while you're
navigating, I'll mention that
Google has kind of a
comprehensive set of libraries
for multiple languages covering
most of the popular
programming languages
that are used now.
So Java, JavaScript,
Ruby, Python, PHP.
There's the list.
And so those are all available
for use now with Google
Compute Engine's API.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yep,
Go, GWT, Java.
So we've got several.
And I used the Python Client
Library to build that sample
application on App Engine.
MARC COHEN: Let's see.
"Is there a free tier that
we could use to test out
applications?" Actually, before
I answer that, one more
thing I wanted to add is-- did
you mention the GCE lib?
KATHRYN HURLEY: No.
Yes, thank you.
MARC COHEN: So there's another
library that you guys should
know about in addition
to the standard
Google Client Libraries.
Kathryn's bringing it up
on a page right now.
So this is called GCE lib, and
this is kind of a reference
library for what we think
is a really great
abstraction layer in Python.
So it's specific to Python,
but we think it's a really
nice programming paradigm.
And we'd like to recommend
people give it a try.
Really natural object-oriented
structure for accessing the
Compute Engine capabilities.
So that's another option for
people who are interested in
Python programming.
"Is there a free tier that
we could use to test out
applications?"
KATHRYN HURLEY: That's a good
question, and I'm not sure of
the answer.
MARC COHEN: Yeah.
I think the answer is
that right now, yes,
there is a free tier.
We haven't officially set the
rules as far as the free
quota, when that's going
to be introduced.
So right now, all
access is free.
But we're definitely moving to
a model where we're going to
be charging.
And the pricing for the charging
for our service is on
that same page that's in the
second link on Kathryn's page.
Or actually, yeah--
KATHRYN HURLEY: Down here.
MARC COHEN: So if you go to
developers.google.com.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Dot pricing.
MARC COHEN: Yeah, so right
now, we're in the limited
preview period.
And during that phase,
the pricing is free.
But we'll have further details
on the actual charging
mechanism when we get to the
next stage of the service.
"Time frame to get access to
test Google Compute Engine
instance?" So this is--
I don't know if you
wanted to--
KATHRYN HURLEY: That's a
good question again.
Lots of good questions.
We just encourage you to sign
up here at this forum.
And we will get to your request
as soon as possible.
So right now, we're spending a
lot of time just making sure
that the service is
running well.
We want to make sure Compute
Engine is the
best that it can be.
So we're in limited preview
right now, as was mentioned.
And so we're letting people in
little by little and making
sure that Compute Engine
is best that it can be.
It is production ready.
We should also mention that.
MARC COHEN: Right.
We do have production Google
services running on this
product, and we just want to
make sure it's going to be the
best possible experience
for all users, so
we're scaling it carefully.
Next question is "Would it be
feasible to boot the instances
with a persistent disk mounted
at root?" My understanding is
the persistent disks have to
be formatted and mounted
yourself, so there might be
sort of a chicken-and-egg
problem there.
But we have one of
our engineering
leads on the Hangout.
I'm not sure if we're able to
switch to include audio from a
Hangout attendee.
Is that possible?
JOE: Can you hear me?
MARC COHEN: There's Joe.
And I'm hearing you, actually.
You might have to speak up.
JOE: OK I hope everybody
else can hear me.
The question about booting from
persistent disk, that's
something that we're working on
and that we're looking at
very carefully.
Obviously, that provides a much
more persistent feel to
the virtual machine than booting
off of ephemeral disk.
We want to make sure that we get
all the right features set
up there so that we
can provide a
great experience there.
But that's definitely the
direction that we're headed.
And then the user will be able
to choose whether they want to
boot from persistent disk
or from ephemeral.
MARC COHEN: Thanks.
Next question is "Do you--"
this changed right
in front of my eyes.
Let's go down the list here.
"Any plans to introduce an
auction-based pricing model
like EC2 Spot Instances?" We'll
consider that input.
We don't currently have specific
plans to do that.
But we really like this kind of
input, so we'll take that
into consideration.
"How secure is this about
hackers and other security
issues?" Really good question.
There's a lot of dimensions to
security, so I just want to
mention a couple of things that
I think make this product
really well situated to
keep your data secure.
A lot of really deep engineering
work has gone into
isolating the instances and the
networks so that when you
actually visit your instance
or interact with your
instance, we've taken great
pains to make sure that other
people's instances can't come
along and see your data or
your instances.
And likewise, you can't get
to other people's data.
And there's a lot of work to
firewall these instances from
Google as well.
It's up to you whether you're
going to use HTTPS or HTTP.
We recommend HTTPS for
encrypting all your data
that's in transit, as
a general rule.
And as Kathryn mentioned, the
data that's stored at rest in
the ephemeral disks
and the persistent
disks is all encrypted.
So the combination of all those
things, we believe,
yields a very secure platform
for application developers.
I don't know, Joe, if you wanted
to add to that at all.
JOE: Yeah, I'd like to add
just a couple things.
I think that's a
great summary.
The first thing is that at the
API level, we're leveraging a
bunch of common technology that
Google has built around
servicing APIs.
And all communication to our
API goes over HTTPS.
And we do things in our clients
like make sure we
check the certificates that we
get back, which is actually a
common problem in API clients.
The next thing is that
our default images--
and we offer both CentOS and
Ubunto-based images.
We've done a little bit of work
or harden these down a
little bit to provide
some good defaults.
Now, we can't go all the way to
sort of guarantee security
for what's running inside
the virtual machine.
I mean, with great power comes
great responsibility, and
having root on the machine means
that there's a certain
amount of ability to shoot
yourself in the foot.
But we've tried to do some
common-sense things.
Like using SSH keys instead
of passwords is a
great way to do this.
We don't allow SSH to
root by default.
We actually disallow password
authentication for SSH.
By default, we've turned on
automatic updates for the
various distributions to make
sure that you get the latest
security packages installed.
Now, you can go in and modify
all of this to turn any of
these capabilities off if you
really want to, but we wanted
to make things be as secure as
we could by default for things
that make sense.
MARC COHEN: Makes sense.
Thanks, Joe.
"How do I configure my instance
on startup?" There's
a couple of answers to that.
KATHRYN HURLEY: A
couple options.
So there are start-up scripts,
and you can specify start-up
script and just run when your
instance says start it up.
And another option is to
create custom image.
So you can also select a custom
image to apply to an
instance while starting.
MARC COHEN: And maybe we can
just really quickly summarize
the process of creating
a custom image.
So you'll create an instance
using one of the standard
default images.
And then you'll customize
that to your needs.
So you might install a web
server or some sort of package
or your own custom application
software that you're
interested in using.
And once you have the
configuration exactly the way
you want it, we have a script
that kind of makes the process
pretty easy.
It writes a compressed tarball
file to the local disk.
And then you store that
in cloud storage.
Then there's an API call you
can make, or it's visible
through gcutil as well, that
you can run to assign a
mnemonic name to the image and
also to tell it which cloud
storage object to use
for that image.
And then from that point
forward, you can create
instances with that tag as
the requested image.
And I think those images will
also show up on the console
API, as far as I know.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes, so you
can select that from the
drop-down menu where you're
creating your instance.
MARC COHEN: So if you prefer
using the web UI, you can go
there and access the images,
create a new image with your
own custom images from
there as well.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And it's
all documented here.
MARC COHEN: Yep.
It's all there.
JOE: I'd love to add something
there real quick.
When you do ahead and register
the image with Compute Engine,
we take a copy of the image
that's in cloud storage.
And so then if you go and change
the underlying bits in
cloud storage, that doesn't
change the image that gets
used a lot.
So it's really once you register
that image with
Compute Engine, it's sort of
locked in at that point.
And you can delete it or create
a different image if
you want to update it.
And then, in general, though,
we've been encouraging users
to use dynamic configuration
software.
I think it's much easier to keep
the image up to date as
bug fixes to our script and the
stuff that we put in our
default images.
Or if you need to recreate
things from scratch, it's a
lot easier to do that with
dynamic systems.
The easiest thing is the
start-up script that Kathryn
managed, but if you're building
a larger system, you
can start taking on systems like
Chef or Puppet or more
full-blown providers
like Bright Scale.
So this really, when Kathryn
mentioned earlier the idea of
building an ecosystem, that's
really some of the stuff that
we're talking about, is being
able to plug into a lot of
these management systems that
have been built up as people
have started learning how
to use the cloud.
MARC COHEN: There's kind of a
fine line between the custom
image capability and the
start-up script capability.
And just from my own playing
with the product, I tend to
use the start-up capability
as my iterative
experimentation mechanism.
And then when I've got something
that's relatively
solid, I'll convert to a custom
image, just because the
start-up thing is more dynamic
and lower overhead.
Next question.
ANDREW: Sorry, I might just add
something, because I've
just recently been building out
a service on big cluster
for an internal project that
we'll be launching soon.
JOE: You need Google
Compute Engine.
ANDREW: Oh, sorry.
Sorry, Joe.
MARC COHEN: It's OK.
ANDREW: My experience with the
start-up scripts is actually
really great.
And one of the features that
I really enjoyed was the
metadata service so that you
can assign a key value
metadata to individual
instances.
And then there's a RESTful
interface for accessing those
metadata values.
And I actually ended up building
my service in my
server daemon, the capability
to query that metadata.
And so I was able to do live
configuration of my--
I'm running services just by
using the Compute Engine API.
So I don't know if you--
that's probably a subject for
another Hangout, but I think
that metadata capability is
really, really awesome.
And I'm kind of partial to
using start-up scripts as
opposed to building images
because I find that the
ability to iterate on something
that is just built
live every time is really
compelling to me.
KATHRYN HURLEY: One thing I
found useful as far as images
are concerned, though, is on
some of my instances--
actually, the ones in the demo
that I had that created
fractal image, I wanted
to install Java.
And installing Java in the
start-up script did take a
little bit of time.
So having an image with Java
installed already did make a
little bit faster.
ANDREW: Yeah, well, I'm a Go
programmer, so deployment in
Go is just shipping a binary, so
that's a non-issue for me.
MARC COHEN: There's some really
nice things that just
work in the start-up script.
And I think a lot of it is that
the networking is set up
to just do the right thing and
that you have access to root
with sudo, and you have the
frictionless gsutil.
All that stuff just being there
from the first second
the instance comes up
is super powerful.
So you want to install
a package in
that start-up script.
You do a sudo apt-get of some
package, and it just installs.
There's no friction.
So I would echo what
Andrew said.
From my experience, it's a
really nice environment for
iteratively building
these systems.
ANDREW: And also, compared to
other virtual machine systems
that I've used, the start-up
times for Compute Engine are
really, really great.
Like the turnaround time for
restarting an instance is
usually between a minute
and 30 seconds, or
less, in some cases.
And that's just been awesome.
MARC COHEN: I've been working on
a demo that involves 1,000
VM cluster, and that's been
pretty important to me, the
speed with which I can
start that cluster up
and iterate on it.
So I would agree.
ANDREW: I wanted to ask a
question about the start-up
scripts, though.
Is it correct that they run
every time the instant starts?
So if the instance restarts, the
setup script is run again?
Is that correct?
And is the ephemeral disk
totally wiped if
the instance restarts?
MARC COHEN: Well, it depends
what you mean by "restart." So
a reboot will not wipe
the ephemeral disk.
If the VM has some sort of
failure where it fails in a
hard way, then the ephemeral
disk would be lost.
JOE: So our behavior
then there is--
I think it's natural for
actually how we develop
software at Google.
But I think it's a little bit
of a change from what people
might be expecting from
outside of Google.
Currently, when we see a failure
in a virtual machine--
so this usually is a
software-hardware failure.
And we're obviously working to
make sure that it's only a
hardware failure and do what
we can to minimize that.
But when that virtual machine
fails, we'll just restart it
with the same parameters.
So if you're looking at
something like the demo that
you saw earlier, where you're
waiting on some sort of signal
to do some work, or you're just
reading from a queue to
just do some back work, that's
really a natural thing to do,
that the VM will fail.
It'll come back, and then it'll
start picking up a few
items and start working on it.
We're going to be looking to
provide expanded options in
terms of communicating and
dealing with those failure
situations in the future.
That's one of the things that
we're looking at, figuring out
what's the best way
to handle that?
What's the best way to
communicate that stuff?
What kind of other tools can
we provide around that?
And things like booting off
a persistent disk that was
mentioned earlier as a question
is definitely
part of that plan.
That being said, the only time
that you'll typically see a
reboot of the virtual machine,
short of these failures, is
that you type reboot from inside
the virtual machine.
And in that case, you will
see the start-up
script be run again.
If you want to detect whether
you're actually seeing the
first boot or the second boot,
with the start-up script, you
can write a sentinel file
someplace on the file system
to actually sort of say, oh,
I've been through this code
path before, and detect that.
One of the other things I want
to point out-- and I think
this is documented in
our documentation.
It's a really useful thing
for a start-up script.
There's a safe format and
mount helper script that
essentially--
like we have this idea of
extended ephemeral disks or
persistent disks.
And if you want to mount these
things and format them, if
they haven't already been
formatted, that's something
that we provide a helper
script to do.
And then that helps to prevent
data loss in case of one of
these unexpected reboots for
both extended ephemeral disks
or the persistent disk.
And then also to help make sure
that you know which disk
you're talking about when you
attach a persistent disk, you
can actually provide an alias
that shows up in the dev file
system so that instead of
knowing, oh, it's BDA, BDB, or
SDA, FDB, or SDC, or whatever,
we actually create an alias
there that makes it easy
to have stable
connections to that.
So that's another hint there.
MARC COHEN: Cool.
Thanks.
Let's see.
Next one is "How much visibility
do Google admins
have into my machine?" That's
probably a Joe question.
JOE: Very little.
I mean, we've tried very hard
to make sure that we provide
as many walls and protections
as we can.
We really take customers' data
very, very seriously.
This is one of the reasons
why we've done that
encryption at rest.
We do have access to the
machines, and the keys have to
be stored someplace.
But we have a lot of internal
control to make sure that
before anybody takes a look at
that stuff, that all that
stuff gets audited and that
very few people have
permission to be able to do
anything that you could
possibly get to that data.
So we're very, very careful
about, and we really take
great pains to make sure
that we limit as
much access as possible.
We actually segment and control
those keys very, very
carefully, and we control access
very, very carefully.
MARC COHEN: Here's another one
that may be for you, Joe.
Somebody says, "Ive seen you
have custom-built images based
on Ubuntu and CentOS.
What has been changed on them,
and will people release them
for our own servers?" And you
mentioned earlier that we've
locked things down so that by
default, it kind of errs on
the side of security, but
maybe you can share.
JOE: So the first question,
what has been changed?
We create these images by doing
a dev bootstrap from the
ground up and just install--
at least for Ubuntu, we
do a dev bootstrap up.
For CentOS, I think we pick
an Iso and install it.
And then we go through, and
we do make a bunch of
modifications.
Most of those things are
additive in terms of adding
some extra scripts to be able to
run those start-up scripts
or to customize the device file
system for those aliases
that I mentioned earlier.
One of the things that I'd like
to see us do is document
exactly what we've changed there
and really get down to
the details.
In terms of releasing these
things, all the software
that's available on these
images is available from
either in-source form on the
images themselves, so we don't
have any binaries deployed
there, and anything that's a
binary is available via the
ways that you can download
source from the distributions.
So with respect to being able
to get the source for
open-source software, that's the
way that we could go ahead
and do that.
In terms of releasing the images
themselves as a whole,
that's not something that
we've thought about.
It something that--
it's a good piece of data.
But most of the customizations
that we've made to these
images are to make them work
well in the Compute Engine
environment.
So I'm not quite sure how much
sense it would make to have
these things run elsewhere.
MARC COHEN: Cool.
Thanks, Joe.
A business and investment
question.
"Do you foresee App
Engine being
cannibalized by Compute Engine?
What should we be using?
What should we be advising
clients?" I can take a crack
at that, unless you
wanted to--
KATHRYN HURLEY: Go ahead.
Amy might have some
input, too.
MARC COHEN: Yeah, we'll
ask Amy in a minute.
My quick reaction
is not at all.
In fact, we think that the
combination of the two
products are awesome.
There was a talk at I/O where
an engineer and a product
manager showed a really cool
demo where the two products
worked together really well.
In my own experience, I've been
playing around with the
combination of those
two a little bit.
And App Engine works super
nicely as kind of an
orchestrator of these virtual
machines in the back end.
And it's almost like a similar
concept to the task queues or
the App Engine back ends,
although those have different
capabilities and different
features.
But the quick answer is, I think
they work really well
together and complement
each other.
I don't know if Amy or anybody
else wanted to add to that.
AMY: Yeah.
Can you guys hear me?
MARC COHEN: Might need to
speak up a little bit.
Your audio's low.
KATHRYN HURLEY: And Amy is
our App Engine expert.
MARC COHEN: Right.
Thanks.
AMY: I just concur and
say that they're very
complementary.
And I'd recommend that
you check out
the Google I/O session.
It's very interesting.
And one thing that we probably
don't have time to get into in
this Hangout, but quite a nice
pattern, how Compute Engine
instances were accessing tasks
on an App Engine pool queue to
control what they were doing.
And that's a very nice way
to view the interaction.
And at the App Engine end,
there was also some load
distribution, load
balancing of the
Compute Engine instances.
It was quite nice.
It's sort of different levels
of abstraction.
MARC COHEN: Maybe we can have a
session down the road a bit
where we could perhaps work
with the App Engine, do a
joint one of these sessions with
the App Engine team and
just kind of focus on that
subject entirely.
ANDREW: I can probably speak to
this a little bit as well,
because the service I'm building
at the moment uses
both App Engine and
Compute Engine.
So just to give you a sort of
vague idea of the architecture
and the division between each
is that it's essentially a
game, a multiuser game.
And so the user interface
is also served by
the App Engine app.
So users join a session, and the
sessions are all tracked
in the App Engine data store.
And scores and settings and all
that are tracked by App
Engine, and static content
is also by App Engine.
And then, when the users
actually start interacting
with each other in real time,
they make web socket
connections to Compute
Engine instances.
So they're able to do real-time,
low-latency
communication between players
but with all of the state and
all of the sort of the typical
web-appy stuff is being
handled by App Engine.
And so there was a really nice
division there, and the
respective APIs of each
made it really easy
to construct this.
And I look forward to sharing
it in more detail.
We're going to open source it
and make it widely available.
So that should be
a great example.
MARC COHEN: That'd be awesome.
And the other thing is, about 10
minutes ago, we just saw an
example of an App Engine app
that orchestrated VMs.
Because I think you mentioned,
Kathryn's app is App Engine
based, and it works really
nicely that way.
Can you show the test
sign-up links again?
Maybe you can do
that while I--
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yes.
Let me just find that.
MARC COHEN: --look
down the list for
another question here.
KATHRYN HURLEY: There we go.
Oops.
MARC COHEN: While you're doing
that, I'll just read off one
of these. "Do you provide
an API so that I can
programmatically manage my
compute instances?" Hopefully,
everyone on this Hangout knows
the answer to that.
And the answer is yes.
APIs and client libraries, as
we discussed at length.
"There is an interaction between
this product and all
Google products.
How?" That's a pretty
broad question.
So Kathryn, thanks for putting
the sign-up link on there.
So you can see the link up on
the screen right now, if
you're interested in
that sign-up URL.
Yes, there are many interactions
between this
product and other
Google products.
One that seems pretty clear is
the ability to use Google APIs
from these virtual machines.
So all the great stuff that
you know and love--
Docs and Apps and the Data API
and Maps and everything should
be usable from a VM.
But the cloud APIs,
in particular, are
all usable as well.
And as we mentioned earlier,
we've taken pains to try to
make some of that work more
easily by taking care of or
minimizing some of the
complexity of the process of
obtaining access tokens,
using the OAuth
authority delegation mechanism.
And we also talked about App
Engine interactions with
Compute Engine.
So there are lots of ways that
Compute Engine interacts with
Google products.
And one of the things we're
really excited about is for
you guys to start mashing things
up in interesting and
unique ways that maybe we
haven't even thought of yet.
"Do you like Google?" Yes.
KATHRYN HURLEY: That is one
of the questions on mine.
MARC COHEN: That's a
pretty easy one.
Obviously, we're getting
pretty far
down on the list here.
"Do you have any plans to allow
deployments to more data
centers, for example, Europe and
Asia?" And we definitely
want to expand our footprint,
but I'm not sure about what
specifics we can talk
about at this point.
I don't know, Joe, if you
know what we can say.
JOE: I don't think we have
anything to really talk about
right there.
I mean, obviously, one of the
advantages of Compute Engine
that we didn't have a chance to
touch on is the fact that
it takes advantage of Google's
global footprint in a lot of
ways, and specifically,
our network footprint.
And one of the ways that this
manifests is that if you have
a bunch of virtual machines in
different regions-- because
right now, we have three
different regions
with a zone in each.
And they all sit on
a virtual network.
They can talk to each other
across regions, even though
those regions might be separated
by large distances.
And we're going to look to
maintain that type of
capability as we scale out
geographically, also.
So as we do look to actually
have a larger footprint
geographically, we want to
make sure that we make it
really easy to integrate instead
of having to build a
bunch of cross-region special
code to do that stuff.
MARC COHEN: Cool.
Here's an interesting
question.
"Are the Google APIs accessed
from within Compute Engine
over Google's internal network
or over public internet?
Can you describe more which
traffic goes where?"
JOE: So all connections between
a Compute Engine
instance and any API go over,
logically, the public internet.
They go out through our gateway,
and Google sees them
come back in with a
public IP address.
So if you have an instance that
doesn't have a public IP
address, it can access the
internet, including whether
that be the cloud storage APIs
or whether that be the Compute
Engine APIs or what have you.
That being said, practically,
that data never leaves
Google's networks.
It just hairpins at a certain
point and comes right back in.
In addition, most
of these APIs--
all of these APIs, I believe--
are accessible over HTTPS.
So if you're worried about
security and eavesdropping and
things, you 't have to
worry about that.
And we're actively monitoring,
making sure that we can
provide the best performance
available, specifically
between Compute Engine and
Google Cloud storage, because
we know that the connection
there is really, really
critical as people fill
out the applications.
MARC COHEN: Thanks.
And maybe we have--
getting down to the wire here.
One more question, maybe?
"Do you provide--" no, we
already hit that one.
"Would it be feasible to do
socket connections between App
Engine and GCE?" I think we
touched on that one, too.
Did you say you were
using web sockets,
Andrew, in your Go app?
So I think we--
ANDREW: Yeah, that's right.
MARC COHEN: --we
verified that.
And yep, that's fully
supported.
I think we're kind of out of
questions, but we're kind of
out of time at the same time.
KATHRYN HURLEY: So thanks,
again, everyone--
MARC COHEN: Thanks to everybody
for participating.
KATHRYN HURLEY: --that is
watching online, and everybody
trying to hang out as well.
Thanks.
MARC COHEN: Thanks, folks.
We'll do more.
KATHRYN HURLEY: Yep,
stay tuned.
We will.
[MUSIC PLAYING]